>> Sandra: JOE BIDEN PREPARING
TO ROLL OUT THE COVID-19
VACCINE WHEN HE TAKES OFFICE.
YESTERDAY PROMISING TO
DISTRIBUTE 100 MILLION DOSES TO
ALL AMERICANS DURING HIS FIRST
100 DAYS IN OFFICE.
ALL THE WHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP
PROMISED TO DO ESSENTIALLY THE
SAME FOR AMERICANS AT HIS
VACCINE SUMMIT YESTERDAY.
FOX NEWS MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR
DR. MARC SIEGEL JOINS US NOW.
IT WAS REMARKABLE YESTERDAY THE
SORT OF SPLIT SCREEN THAT WAS
HAPPENING WHILE THE PRESIDENT
WAS HOLDING THAT VACCINE SUMMIT
EXPLAINING JUST HOW THIS
ROLL-OUT WILL HAPPEN JOE BIDEN
WAS ON OTHER NETWORKS UNVEILING
THE MEMBERS OF HIS NEW TEAM.
POLITICS PLAYS A BIG PART IN
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE MEDICINE
SIDE OF THIS PANDEMIC.
WHAT ESSENTIALLY WILL HAPPEN?
WILL ALL AMERICANS BE ABLE TO
GET THIS VACCINE?
>> THE ANSWER TO THAT IS YES,
SANDRA.
YOU NAILED THE ISSUE.
IT IS POLITICS.
THE REALITY IS THAT BOTH ARE
TRUE.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU WILL SEE
PROBABLY 20 MILLION DOSES OF
THE VACCINES OR EVEN 40 MILLION
DOSES, 20 MILLION PEOPLE
GETTING VACCINATED BY THE TIME
THIS PRESIDENT LEAVES OFFICE
BECAUSE OF WHAT YOU SAW
YESTERDAY.
THE GREAT PLANS THAT ARE IN
PLACE WITH FedEx AND UPS
INVOLVED AND WITH THE UNITED
STATES MILITARY OVERSEEING
EVERYTHING.
AND WITH CDC AND THEY EXPLAINED
THEMSELVES YESTERDAY.
ALL OF THAT IS HAPPENING.
JOE BIDEN TAKES OFFICE AND YES,
I THINK HE PROBABLY WILL BE
ABLE TO GET 100 MILLION PEOPLE
VACCINATED IN THE FIRST 100
DAYS OF HIS TERM.
THAT’S AMBITIOUS BUT I SEE BOTH
HAPPENING.
WHAT BIDEN WILL DO IS BUILD ON
WHAT’S ALREADY THERE.
HE DOESN’T WANT TO SAY THAT.
SO IT WILL BE A COMBINATION.
HE IS BASICALLY COMMITTING TO A
PROGRAM THAT IS ALREADY IN
PLACE.
WHAT HE MAY DO DIFFERENTLY IS
HE MAY LOOK TO VACCINATE GROUPS
THAT ARE BEING OVERLOOKED RIGHT
NOW OR GROUPS THAT WE CAN’T
REACH RIGHT NOW.
RIGHT NOW THE PRIORITIES ARE
CLEARLY TO GET NURSING HOMES
VACCINATED BECAUSE OF 40% OF
THE COVID DEATHS OCCURRING IN
NURSING HOMES AND HEALTHCARE
WORKERS.
>> Sandra: I ALSO WANT TO ASK
YOU ABOUT THESE PROBLEMS THAT
HAVE POPPED UP IN THE FIRST DAY.
WE SAW THE U.K. VACCINATE THE
FIRST WOMAN TO RECEIVE IT, 90
YEARS OLD YESTERDAY.
BUT OTHER PEOPLE GETTING THE
FIRST DOSES OF THE VACCINE.
HERE IS THE DAILY MAIL HEADLINE
THIS MORNING.
WARNING OVER U.K. VACCINE
ROLL-OUT AT TWO NHS STAFF
MEMBERS SUFFER ANAPHYLACTIC
REACTIONS.
REGULATORS ARE URGING PEOPLE
WITH SIGNIFICANT ALLERGIES NOT
TO HAVE THE INJECTION JUST 24
HOURS AFTER BRITAIN’S MASS
INOCULATION KICKED OFF.
IF SOMEONE HAS ALLERGIES, ARE
THEY SUPPOSED TO NOT GET THE
VACCINE FOR NOW?
>> NO, SANDRA.
I’M SO GLAD YOU ARE BRINGING
THIS UP.
VACCINE HESITANCY IS A BIG
PROBLEM IN THE UNITED STATES
AND THE WORLD.
LET’S KEEP IN MIND THE PFIZER
VACCINE HAS BEEN TESTED ON OVER
20,000 PEOPLE IN THE U.S. AND
OVER 50,000 PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD.
AND WHAT THAT MESSAGE IS
BASICALLY THIS, IT IS NOT JUST
ALLERGIES, IF YOU HAVE A
HISTORY OF WHAT IS CALLED AN
ANAPHYLACTIC REACTION WHERE YOU
GET A BIG RASH, START TO SWELL
UP, BLOOD PRESSURE GOES DOWN.
IT’S A BIG, BIG REACTION, NOT
SOMETHING WHERE YOU GET AN ITCH
OR SCRATCH OR SNIFFLES.
PEOPLE OUT THERE NEED TO KNOW
THIS IS BEING DONE OUT OF AN
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION, NOT
BECAUSE THERE IS A GREAT
CONCERN THAT THIS VACCINE
CAUSES HUGE ALLERGIES OR IS A
BIG RISK FOR PEOPLE WITH
ALLERGIES.
VERY SAFE VACCINE BUT WE NEED
TO GIVE IT TO MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE NOW.
>> Sandra: SO IMPORTANT TO KEEP
THE FACTS FLOWING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE OVER THIS